the jurgen experience let's crack a
lacking um well
are you ready to get wasted yeah you and
this [ __ ]
you and this [ __ ] vile beverage that
you bring
i brought lord
i was like joe is going to actually be
mad
to people what this is okay
i brought rycia uh
joe rogan this man right here he talks
about racial i talk about it he
well i give it to people and every time
i give it to people they're like jesus
i don't know it's one of the rare
alcohols that we've had in studio that
we haven't burned through
yeah and i noticed you didn't give it to
snoop
squandered opportunity i was like you're
like yeah you don't want that i was like
maybe he does we can't take a chance
with snoop okay so braycia is moonshine
from the state of jalisco which is where
i live in mexico and it's similar to
mezcal so it comes from the agave plant
and that is the end of my explanation
because after that i am confused
i don't know why you like it i don't
know why either like i have no i'm not
like i don't love most booze like really
i love drinking but like i love whiskey
i love scotch i love where i see it so
you like strong stuff i don't like
tequila i don't like vodka yeah i don't
like rum yeah you're a strong drinker
well obviously if you like ricea you're
a strong drinker you like
you like stuff you feel yeah but i mean
what i
i can't explain it like i can't explain
why i don't like tequila but i like
racial which everybody else hates okay
thank you explain [ __ ] like megan just
do you you do
like yeah exactly so okay so what i
brought
this is actual moonshine it's it didn't
come in this bottle my friend put it in
this bottle for me but she actually
bought it from
on the top of a mountain in yalapa from
a guy
i've tried it
it's okay
no
no it's not gonna kill you
i mean yeah i mean does it kill you no
no no it's good i mean they've been
making this stuff for centuries so they
put in that bottle did you they sell it
out of two liter coke bottles
i feel like that's
what this came out of a two liter like
coke bottle yeah we have to try that one
i want to look i want to look at your
face okay are we putting it in mugs yeah
why not i mean [ __ ] it this is not
formal
no we're not getting these coffee mugs
here because i'm probably going to pour
coffee in it later and just go
dude you're going to hate this i promise
and then after i'm going to give you
some that you might actually like and if
you don't like it then i give up on you
forever oh no
i'm a whiskey and we're not friends
anymore
i love whiskey too buffalo treasure
always that's my kind of [ __ ] okay
cheers my friend cheers nice to see you
again very good to see you okay
oh
boy
i just got ricey all over my face
and that's what happens when you drink
out of mugs it tastes like it came from
a [ __ ] coke bottle
do you like it at all like i don't know
i kind of like it
obviously
you're like i mean
let me tell you like
well megan oh you're a strong cup of
coffee as a human you know and it makes
sense that you would like a strong
beverage okay thank you yeah that
actually makes sense i appreciate that
makes sense yeah
you know
it fits you this and this is like it's
either 47 or 48 proof and the way that
they test the proof they ain't tested
[ __ ] is by she showed me a video my
friend showed me a video and the the guy
who was making it put it in this little
thing and then blue bubbles with a straw
and then he looks at the bubbles like he
looks at the size of the bubbles and
sees like how fast they pop and that's
how you know
oh super accurate
is he snake charm as well
like what the [ __ ]
this one i bought from the bar across
the street from my house
because i really i really loved i was
like this is so good yeah and i couldn't
find it anywhere like i couldn't buy it
anywhere
so is that a popular beverage with
mexicans or is it a popular beverage
with the expats
uh more like mexicans like for example
beautiful yeah this one is beautiful i
love the little you might this one
actually to me tastes more like a mezcal
do you like mascara
like this one is smokier
um
so you might like this one
but i also like the bottle i like how
the bottle comes with that little
necklace yeah you can wear that if you
want not